♪ ♪
>> Tucker: UNNOTICED BY MOST
PEOPLE WAS THE LAND REFORM
PROVISION IN THE DEMOCRATS MOST
RECENT CORONAVIRUS RELIEF BILL
THAT ALLOCATED BILLIONS TO
SO-CALLED FARMERS OF COLOR.
AT THE SAME TIME, THAT BILL
DENIES MONEY TO FARMERS WHO HAVE
THE WRONG SKIN COLOR.
THAT IS, BY DEFINITION, RACISM.
WHAT IS CLEARLY ILLEGAL UNDER
THE LAW AND THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ACT.
NOW, SEVERAL FARMERS ARE SUING
OVER IT, AS THEY SHOULD, BUT
MSNBC DOESN'T LIKE THAT.
MSNBC RAN A SEGMENT ACCUSING
MOST FARMERS OF BEING WHITE
SUPREMACISTS.
>> AND REALLY, YOU KNOW, HIS
GROUP, AMERICA FIRST LEGAL, A
MORE ACCURATE NAME FOR IT WOULD
BE WHITE MEN FIRST LEGAL,
BECAUSE IT REALLY IS ABOUT
ATTACKING ANY EFFORTS TO MAKE
SOCIETY MORE EQUITABLE FOR
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES, AND SO
FAR, ALL ITS DOING AND TRYING TO
DO IS TO CREATE HYSTERIA AROUND
EFFORTS TO MAKE SOCIETY A MORE
LIVABLE PLACE FOR BROWN AND
BLACK COMMUNITIES, FOR WOMEN,
FOUR, YOU KNOW, FOR ANYONE WHO
IS NOT A WHITE MAN.
>> Tucker: ADAM FAUST IS NOT
THE PICTURE OF PRIVILEGE.
HE RUNS A FARM.
HE HAS LOST BOTH HIS FEET.
HE IS ONE OF THE FARMERS SUING
OVER THIS RACIST LAW.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT WITH HIS
ATTORNEY, RICK S AND BIRD.
ADAM AND RICK, THANK YOU BOTH
FOR COMING OUT TONIGHT.
ADAM, SUMMARIZE FOR US WHY YOU
ARE FILING THIS SUIT, IF YOU
WOULD?
>> WELL, BASICALLY, JUST BECAUSE
RACISM -- I MEAN, RACISM AGAINST
ANYBODY IS WRONG.
WE CAN'T HAVE A GOVERNMENT
PICKING AND CHOOSING WHO THEY
ARE GOING TO GIVE ANY PROGRAM TO
BASED SOLELY ON THE COLOR OF
THEIR SKIN.
>> Tucker: SO, YOU GREW UP IN
THIS COUNTRY, I CAN TELL BY YOUR
ACCENT.
WERE YOU TALK ALL ALONG THE WAY
THAT IS CONTRARY TO THE
CONSTITUTION, MARTIN LUTHER KINF
AMERICA.
ARE YOU SURPRISED BY THIS?
>> EXTREMELY.
LIKE YOU SAID, EVERYTHING THAT
WE HAVE ALL LEARNED GROWING UP
HIS RACISM WAS WRONG, AND NOW,
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SEEMS TO THINK THAT
RACISM IS ACCEPTABLE IN CERTAIN
WAYS.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
>> SHOULD NEVER BE ACCEPTABLE.
>> Tucker: NO, IT SHOULDN'T BE
PURIFIED IF YOU COMPLAIN ABOUT
IT, YOU ARE A WHITE SUPREMACIST.
SO, RICK, HOW CAN THIS LAW BE
LEGAL?
I DON'T REMEMBER ANYONE POINTING
IT OUT WHEN IT PASSED, BUT I
THOUGHT THERE WERE FEDERAL LAWS
THAT BANNED THIS TYPE OF
DISCRIMINATION.
>> IT CAN'T BE.
OUR COURTS HAVE MADE CLEAR FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS, TUCKER, THAT
THE RIGHT TO BE FREE OF RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION IS AN INDIVIDUAL
RIGHT THAT WE ALL HAVE.
IT IS NOT A GROUP RIGHT.
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS A NINE
DISCRIMINATION.
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS A
LITTLE MAKEUP DISCRIMINATION TO
EVEN THINGS OUT.
YOU KNOW, WHEN MSNBC COMMENTATOR
TALKS ABOUT EQUITY, WE ARE ALL
FOR LAWS THAT PROHIBIT
DISCRIMINATION, BUT THOSE LAWS
HAVE TO APPLY ACROSS THE BOARD,
TO PEOPLE LIKE ADAM, AS WELL AS
TO BLACK AND HISPANIC FARMERS.
>> Tucker: SO, IF THE NEXT
ADMINISTRATION SAID WE ARE
PICKING A DIFFERENT RACIAL GROUP
AND WE ARE GOING TO SEND THEM
MONEY BECAUSE OF HOW THEY WERE
BORN, I MEAN, DO YOU THINK THAT
WOULD MAKE IT THROUGH THE
COURTS?
WOULD THAT GO UNNOTICED?
>> NO, IT WOULDN'T.
I MEAN, LOOK, WE FOUGHT A CIVIL
WAR.
WE HAD A LENGTHY CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
PRINCIPAL THAT WAS IN OUR
FOUNDING DOCUMENTS, THAT WE ARE
ALL TO BE TREATED AS
INDIVIDUALS, AND THIS REALLY
DISTURBING MOOD WE HAVE ABOUT
EQUITY INSTEAD OF EQUALITY OF
OPPORTUNITY WILL NOT END WELL,
IT WILL LEAD, AS I THINK YOU ARE
POINTING OUT, TO A WAR AGAINST
ALL, WHERE WE ALL ARE LOOKING
FOR OUR RACIAL SPOILS, AND THAT
IS SIMPLY NOT WHAT AMERICA IS
ABOUT, AND I'M SO GLAD THAT ADAM
IS WILLING TO STAND UP AND FIGHT
THIS NOW, BEFORE -- BEFORE IT
BECOMES FAR MORE ACCEPTABLE THAN
IT IS.
THIS IS IMMORAL AND IT IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND ILLEGAL.
>> Tucker: WELL, IT'S TOTALLY
IMMORAL.
ADAM, QUICK, ARE YOU SURPRISED
YOU ARE BEING ATTACKED IS A BAD
PERSON FOR STANDING UP AGAINST
RACISM?
>> YEAH, IT DOES SURPRISE ME,
SINCE WHAT WE ARE DOING IS
ANTIRACIST.
WE ARE FIGHTING RACISM FOR
EVERYBODY IN THE COUNTRY, NOT
JUST ONE GROUP, AND YET SOME
PEOPLE SEEM TO THINK THAT BEING
ANTIRACIST IS NOW RACIST.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
YOU DON'T SEEM VERY PRIVILEGED
TO ME.
I AM ROOTING FOR YOU, AND IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY, PEOPLE OF ALL
COLORS.
THIS IS A PRINCIPLE WE HAV